there's a ramen shop on rishiri island  off the northern tip of japan  to get there from tokyo fly two hours to  sapporo  from there take the train to akane the  northernmost city in japan  you then catch a ferry to rishiri island  make your way to the western part of the  island and once you're there  let's hope you're on time it's only open  two and a half hours a day  but the trip is worth it because the  place is said to have some of the best  ramen in all of japan  when it comes to ramen in japan there  are a few places whose names will draw  people from all around the world  ramen miraku is one such place and  visitors come for this special charred  soy ramen made with local kombu seaweed  broth  [Music]  foreign this is no instant ramen  making the dish takes hours  [Music]  from  [Music]  [Music]  the question of course why do you think  people come all this way  [Music]  our turn one charred ramen please  wow this is good